voici ces fameux barrage flottant
installé devant un complexe hôtelier de
luxe de saint-françois en guadeloupe
c'est le gérant de l'établissement qui
lui même a cherché une solution adaptée
pour protéger son ac ont pénalisé par
les annulations de séjours du à
l'invasion des sargasses il a trouvé une
entreprise à nîmes fabricante de toiles
gonflables après discussion voici le
produit conçu pour l'occasion
des boudins de 15 mètres de long ni bout
à bout il y en a ici plus de 200 m c'est
un boudin gonflable qui est incorporé
dans une jupe ici de l'an on le gonfle
par ici après cette jupe est la honte
ont à leur tour le bouddha elle continue
sur 80 cm et au bout de la jupe vous
avez une chaîne qui est resté mais quand
on met le boudin dans l'eau la jupe
vient à droite et vous avez les à lui
qu'il dise dessus s'il ya un courant
glissant
le coût pour 200 m 12000 euros 27 milan
comptant l'installation des encres qui
empêchent l'installation de dérivés et
lorsque les algues ne sont plus là tout
se dégonfle et se replient facilement
l'hôtelier de saint françois a retrouvé
sa plage et sont accomplis depuis trois
ans on n'a jamais fait venir un
tractopelle pour enlever les algues
parce qu'il ya plus talk sur la plage
regardez d'ailleurs il n'ya pas de
sargasses c'est pour le bien de tous du
coup l'entreprise voilà un marché à
prendre aux antilles ici sur la route de
cul de sac ferrer la ville du marin a
demandé une étude aux fabricants les
conditions d'installation par est idéal
en raison d'une houle modérée et de
nombreuses options sont possibles entre
200 et 1200 mètres de barrages a minima
il faut considérer linéaire de pointe en
pointe avec bien sûr une ouverture pour
permettre aux marins pêcheurs de pouvoir
quand même circuler de pointe en pointe
nous avons un linéaire grosso modo de
230 à 250 m donc ça c'est un premier
niveau de barrage je pense qu'il y a
également nécessité de protéger à minima
la plage du cap may cry pour bien faire
un engin de ramassage en mer très
complémentaire de ces barrages qui ne
font que dévier les sargasses une
installation qui nécessite également une
a ôté autorisation d'occupation
temporaire délivrée par l'état
l'état qui de toute façon serait le
principal financeur